[Musique]
un pe c'est un prêt garanti par l'état
s'adressant aux entreprises et aux
professionnels afin de faire face à la
crise sanitaire actuelle avec un montant
pouvant aller jusqu'à 25% du chiffre
d'affaires les entreprises cibles du pge
est pas pleinement utiliser ce
dispositif il en moyenne utilisée 50% de
leurs capacités
ils ont vraiment eu une attitude
responsable de précaution et ça se voit
d'ailleurs sur la solde de leurs comptes
bancaires ont en revanche on a les
activités telles que les thr et
l'événementiel où il est beaucoup plus
utilisé ce dispositif
[Musique]
deux possibilités soit proche de clients
n'a le remboursement des sommes
empruntées ou l'amortissement avec la
possibilité à la banque l'aval de france
de faire un report supplémentaire de dix
mois sur les premiers retours clients
que nous avons 80 % optent pour un
amortissement sur cinq ans dont 50 %
avec le report supplémentaire 15%
un amortissement entre une et quatre ans
et 7 % sur le remboursement du prêt